[Music]
hey
everybody we're here we're here it's
tuesday right
the second i thought it was wednesday
but i guess not yeah got a good uh some
announcements got a bunch of gifts
uh i got pooky stories then we gotta
talk about this korean flick that we saw
yeah an anthology series i guess you
would call it what do you want to do
first um
i'll tell this cat story yeah this is
this is pretty funny you guys you i know
you guys love the pookie stories
yeah so i get up this morning and i uh
as i'm taking a shower i can see our
walk-in closet from the inside of the
shower you know it's got the little
glass [ __ ] walls to the shower
so i'm looking and pookie's [ __ ]
looking around the corner [ __ ]
calling me and they're running back into
the closet calling me and then
running back in the case trying to show
me something so i'm like
i said i bet you this a lizard in the
[ __ ] glass or a bug or something yeah
or something
ah nah she doesn't get excited about
bugs it's it's
[Laughter]
so i go in there you never drying off
and she's [ __ ] pointing
she's pointing somewhere you know i
don't see anything there but she's beep
beep beep beep
something's there something's there and
i'm going i don't see it
you know i don't see it that [ __ ] went
on a long time
yeah because i can't i came back from my
walk too and she was still doing it
she's like running around
mom mom yeah and she's going to pointing
towards random things in the [ __ ]
walk-in closet going it's here it's here
it's here
i was like man this [ __ ] cat drives
me crazy
so i finally get dressed and i'm talking
jenny goes there it is i see it
and up on the wall was a [ __ ] huge
[ __ ]
tree frog yeah and it's in the closet
like up on the winter
yeah and the problem with the tree frogs
is that the air conditioning kills them
well yeah they dry out they dry out
to get kind of [ __ ] bluish bluish
colored you know
so i could get a [ __ ] stool and reach
up there and [ __ ] grab the frog and
it's
struggling a little bit it didn't even
try to jump and that's how [ __ ] cold
it was
yeah it's like it's helping i took it
outside you know as soon as it hit that
hot air it started getting more lively
oh he was all right yeah and then i put
him i put him uh
on on outside the glass sliding glass
door
and as i took my hand off of him it was
like his skin
fell off but it wasn't it was that you
know that [ __ ]
that slime that they yeah yeah
yeah that's why he looks so blue yeah
that [ __ ] had changed color when it fell
off it was just like a black
film on him i had to wash my hands brody
but uh he lived but the thing is this
[ __ ] funniest thing about cats
is they don't have any eye hand
coordination
they don't understand how hands work
they'll see you pick something up and
they don't understand that you have it
that you took it
and that you put it somewhere because
she kept running right back to the
closet it's in here somewhere
and she saw me grab it yeah and and put
it outside because she was supervising
the whole episode supervised that whole
[ __ ] i mean it was hours because the
thing is i get up really early like i
got up at 6 30 like to go out for my
walk like usual it's still kind of dark
yeah and she was like me me me
and like i was going out the door of the
bedroom and she kept trying to like pull
me back in like me
me like this way and i'm like what's the
matter with you pookie are you out of
treats or something so like and i saw
she still had treats and stuff and i'm
like
well i gotta go whatever and then when i
came back like you said
there's gotta be something in the closet
because she's like wigging out and then
i took a shower and i went in there and
she did the same thing to me she was
like kept running up and
she was trying to like jump up on all
the shelving and stuff she's like
yeah and she was like running around and
started it's in here it's in here
there's nothing in here
yeah oh my god and she was just like
wigging out it was like yeah it was
so yeah but the funny thing is she can
see you pick it up with your hand and
put it outside
and all that [ __ ] goes out the window
she goes right back to the last place
she saw it because it's here it's here
it's here somewhere you guys need to get
there's a monster in the closet take
care of this issue right now
but it's like when you before i saw the
frog i was like is there you know
i was like is timmy down the well what's
the matter looks like everybody's done
here all the regulars are in here
okay um let me see this i got something
in the mail today
yeah and one of the best movies of that
year if you guys haven't seen this [ __ ]
you need to see this yeah i got that
[ __ ] on blu-ray yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
he ordered that i plugged the [ __ ] out
of this movie
and i got vivarium that's also starring
that little [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
that's his name jesse isaac jesse
eisenberg
yeah we didn't give a barium yet but
yeah if you like cobra kai
or [ __ ] karate kid or any of those
little [ __ ]
hokey [ __ ] martial arts movie you got
to see this one
because this one's realistic all right
man i can't wait till the next season
it's not realistic all right
this one reminds this movie reminds me
so much of [ __ ] ninja gym
yeah that character right there
eisenberg's basically playing ninja gym
that's but ninja jim thought he was mad
man he ninja jim was this dude
but he thought but he thought he was mad
max thought he was mad max he was
actually this dude [ __ ] this is a
good move man
it is yeah and i think it was kind of
loosely based off of [ __ ]
the um the go uh the black dragon
fighting society oh aka
dante's dojo yeah that you uh saw the
ads for in the back of the [ __ ] comic
book expect to say
him on the [ __ ] yeah on bushido all
right
but this is [ __ ] an excellent accent
like i also got vivarium coming that'll
be here tomorrow
i loved that one yeah that's good jenny
got a bunch of [ __ ] i got some
movies some more movies from louie i
think he's in the uh
the little chat comments hernandez thank
you very much he's an eagle warrior
a jaguar warrior check this out i'm very
excited about this so i mean i'm not
excited about all the ones he sends but
i'm
particularly excited about these because
look this is the frank langella
dracula the one with that super creepy
scene of like [ __ ]
mina in the mind because mina gets
turned into a vampire instead of lucy
for some reason than this one
and also he sent heat which is a great
[ __ ] movie and i haven't seen that in
a really long time so i'm very very
excited so thank you very much for that
louie also this is hilarious
on the others i can't remember what show
it was but i said something about waffle
fries
and then ken one of our fans said
something about
like making waffle fries or something
like that and i was like oh yeah
you know they actually make like a
machine they can make waffle fries and
today i open a package
from ken yeah
i'll figure out how to use it he has
sent me a multifunctional vegetable
grater with which you may make waffle
fries among other things
yeah if you so desire so thank you very
much ken we will actually definitely
yeah i'll use it yeah because we uh we
have used
the vegetables that we need to wait
mango's saying he's gonna [ __ ] stream
this on my recommendation you're gonna
like that movie mango
yeah that's a [ __ ] good movie it's a
weird movie i like that yeah
just if you like i said if you like
cobra kai if you like those if
you like those martial arts movies this
is kind of like a homage to it
but it's a lot more realistic and it's
kind of modeled after [ __ ] count
dante
from the black dragon society you'll see
he'll like it it's good
real good and it is a comedy but it's i
would call it a very black comedy it's a
black comedy yeah it's like a very
understated
kind of yeah i mean i thought it was
hilarious but yeah i love dark comedy
but you know what's funny is that it
doesn't
what i really liked about the movies
it's funny as [ __ ]
but it does not really ridicule martial
arts or the or the whole concept of
self-defense
in fact the way it ends it actually
kind of uh saves the honor of [ __ ]
concepts like dojos and stuff
yeah it's you'll see what i'm talking
about when you watch a movie
yeah yeah all right so uh you want to
talk about this
movie anthology kind of thing yeah yeah
korean anthology yeah this is
south korea actually i saw that netflix
added i think they added at the end of
august and i was like oh it's kind of
interesting but i saw that it was a
series
so i didn't review it because i thought
to myself oh it's like i don't really
have time like to binge that like for
one of the shows but then i found out
that the episodes themselves are only
like eight minutes long
yeah so it was kind of like so there was
eight episodes i think the last episode
was the longest and that was 15 minutes
so you can pretty much watch the whole
season
in less than an hour which we did you
know how i've been
griping on earlier since some of these
some of these low-budget movies are just
too [ __ ] long
it's all [ __ ] filler you have a very
jaded audience
they know what these stories are if it's
not action-packed
if it's not wall-to-wall entertainment
or something it just can't compete with
modern devices like [ __ ] tablets and
[ __ ] that's why
i liked blood machines a lot it was
short very intense
got right down to the point it kept you
in the movie this is the ultimate
manifestation what i'm talking about
it's almost like
eight chapters of flash fiction yeah
each one's an individual story
trimmed down to the [ __ ] bare bones
and each one's a [ __ ] thrilling short
ride
that's all it is and that's all you need
if you ask me
if i wanted to make an hour-long movie
i'd take
if i make an hour and a half long movie
i'd take uh
a cue from this and put like seven
stories in that [ __ ] have each
like an anthology like an anthology and
have like seven stories and each one
about ten minutes long that's fine
yeah that's that's really how to do it
if you ask me the interesting thing
about this it's called uh goedom
i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing that
right which apparently means
uh urban ghost story or urban legend
so what this is it's basically eight
separate episodes
that each focus on a particular like
korean urban legend or bit of folklore
now the interesting thing i think as far
as i can determine that the the all of
the episodes were um
were directed by the same person but
they're not
it's not like um eight chapters in a
single story it's basically just like
eight short stories some of them
interact like some of them have the same
characters in them or it's the same
setting like two or three of them were
set in the same school and like had one
or two of the characters like in the
background
so it's almost kind of like they're
happening at the same time but they're
not
really all that related you know what
i'm saying um
so uh yeah this was actually pretty good
like some of them are better than others
but
um that's always you're always gonna get
that so
the eight episodes were called um
crack that was the first one um these
these are very much in the line of
you know asian horror where almost all
the ghosts are like
you know the creepy girls with the long
black hair like hanging in front of
their face
and i think only one or two of them
didn't have that um
but there's nothing wrong with that um
there's it's very gory
there's a lot of gore there's a lot of
good practical effects the cgi is
you know not fantastic but it's passable
um but i liked that it was like really
bloody and it got to the point and
everything like that
so the first one uh crack i think is
only five minutes long
uh it's basically just like you know a
ghost in the bathroom like school
bathroom type of story
uh the second one is called destination
uh which was basically
like taxi driver encounters spirit type
of story
a special guest was one that was about
that was the one that was about the girl
that was like um
she was uh like a youtube type celebrity
or whatever
um and she was like
trying to get all these uh points or
something like that like while she was
streaming
and then like weird [ __ ] started
happening like behind her like
poltergeist type [ __ ]
uh so that one was pretty cute uh
curiosity i think was one that was
that was also set in the same school i
think that had to do with like some kind
of like
girl that turned into a monster type of
thing like that was coming out crawling
after that i think i remember that one
the least
um red shoes again is kind of another
one that was
linked to the other ones where it was
just like about a girl
at the same school as some of the other
characters and some of the other shorts
who had been uh hit by a bus or hit by a
train or something like that and had her
legs all [ __ ] up
uh the sixth one dimension was actually
my favorite and uh from the smattering
of reviews i read
other people that reviewed it this seems
to be like a pretty clear favorite
this was the one and i've actually heard
this urban legend i don't know if it's
an urban legend in the us
widely as well but it's a pretty wide
one in asia i guess
where uh they're supposedly like um
if you get in an elevator and you like
go to like a certain number of floors
like in a certain order
like you have to push the buttons in a
certain order whatever it'll take you
like to another dimension
so that was uh so that story was kind of
focusing on that
and i really really liked that one
because that one had really cool
uh it was really really gory and uh it
was really creepy it had like some
creepy kind of uh
imagery to it reminded me a little bit
if you guys have seen the movie called
the i
i think it's a thai movie they made an
american remake but i don't think it was
that good
and there was like a really really
creepy scene that happens in an elevator
in it with like an old man in pajamas
and it's like it's like
really really traumatizing so um this
kind of reminded me of that a little bit
so i liked that one
like the best the whole the whole
anthology is
very [ __ ] filler free soy
free just [ __ ] get to the [ __ ]
point
show us some [ __ ] horror stuff that's
what i really liked about the
the this yeah it's like it didn't go a
lot into like characterization or
something it's just like a situation
yeah like you're just introduced to a
couple characters and then like
a minute in like bad [ __ ] starts
happening yeah and it's
and it's it's very um very action
oriented
it's not dialogue oriented you and you i
don't [ __ ]
i don't speak a lick of [ __ ] korean
and really doesn't matter what they say
the subtitles are planning and they
don't say much
it's just you know what i mean [ __ ]
yeah it's basically like
yeah you you could take the subtitle you
could take the subtitles away and
understand and enjoy the whole movie
yeah you don't really need you don't
need to know
you don't really need it i mean it
probably helps a little bit
maybe like if you get a couple of them
are if you're familiar with
the urban legend that they're talking
about yeah but honestly i think
seven out of eight of them you can kind
of figure out what their legend is
because we have one that's similar
yeah and like i said the elevator one i
had heard of that i don't know if it's
widespread in the us or not but i have
heard of that
it's very action very visual oriented
yeah it's not dialogue driven
which i like that and then the uh the
seven and hold on before but the reason
why i like that a lot of people like oh
that's because you stupid now what it is
is for me
cinema is a visual medium you know what
i mean i'm
i'm more into [ __ ] showing me stuff
don't
tell me things uh if you're gonna tell
me something let's do this in
in in a stage play that's how i you know
i prefer the medium to be
yeah you know what i mean yeah yeah i
mean you're making a movie make the [ __ ]
visual
yeah that's the way i look at it yeah
otherwise write it up
[Laughter]
yeah so uh the seventh episode threshold
this was also a really good one that i
liked
this was basically like a family the mom
and the baby like go off somewhere like
to visit relatives
the dad is home alone and she
specifically says to the dad
i put that uh you know what do they call
it the little paper thing that's like
supposed to be
like supposed to keep bad spirits away
or something like over the door over the
doorway the threshold
japan korea yeah and they're they're
just like oh she's like you better not
move that don't you dare move it never
move it and you know
as soon as she leaves that that's
something that's gonna happen and he's
gonna move it and he's gonna get killed
by the monster so it's like like i said
none of these are
you know super plot heavy note it's
basically like you know
a minute in you get introduced to a
character or two characters and then
like
a monster attacks like pretty much
they're all pretty much like that
because like i said there's not
you know they're like five minutes long
eight minutes long something like that
so they're very short very to the point
like i said it's like flash fiction
and then the third one or the uh the
eighth one rather why'd i say third i
don't know
uh which is the last one is actually the
longest that's 15 minutes
and it's called birth this was the
weirdest one and this one
they did kind of explain they had like
some text at the beginning that kind of
explained the urban legend a little bit
that said that um that there was this
shaman
and she was basically like killing
children and like eating
that was a good one or yeah or like
absorbing their souls or something
and uh the woman that played the shaman
in that was like really
she had some really uh harrowing
facial expressions she was like and she
had like these crazy teeth and [ __ ] hold
on uh louie's in there
uh hey hernandez we got uh the she got
the movies i don't know if you were here
yeah i think he was i think i saw it
earlier yeah yeah
so if you didn't see it like thank you
very much because i'm very excited about
those too
like i said i really really like that
version of dracula and i haven't seen it
in a really long time
but yeah so so uh yeah the eighth one
was
the longest and that was kind of like
you know a child murderer
it's like it's it's a very different
tone
than creep show yeah it's just a korean
anthology it's very
has a very japanese feel to it yeah it's
very it's very asian horror like
i said if you've seen like the creepy
girls with the long hair and [ __ ] very
much like yeah i don't know if you were
here at the beginning it's kind of like
uh
goes along at the same pace as like
maybe blood machines each
each little episode is only like five to
eight minutes long
yeah stripped down to bare bones bones
just visual horror
it's good there's no there's no filler
in it
yeah and um you know it's it's a soy
free product it gets right down to the
pro
to to business and shows you some
[ __ ] scary [ __ ] that's what it does
yeah that's i liked it i liked it it was
good i did too like i said i liked some
better than
i think the elevator one uh dimension
and threshold were my favorites
they were all good none of them were bad
but they were all good like none of them
were sucky oh and the taxi one was
pretty good too i like that one like
with the
with the creepy girl on the back the
priestess one the elevator one the taxi
one
they think those were my favorite ones
those yeah the most the one with the
girl that went to the bathroom that was
pretty
pretty interesting that was the first
one the very first one yeah yeah because
there were like several
like half of them were kind of about
girls in a school and like that should
happen to them to school those were like
less memorable i guess because they were
kind of like all similar
um so i think the ones that stood out
were the ones that kind of like went in
a different direction yeah it's worth
watching it goes by real fast
what was that that was netflix it was on
netflix netflix yeah yeah
um so yeah that's still there like i
said i think they just added it
and so i'm glad we actually got around
to watching it because i don't even know
why
i don't know i was like looking for new
[ __ ] and i was just kind of like oh
that's a series that's too bad but then
i was like i clicked on it anyway and
then i was like oh the episodes are only
like [ __ ] five minutes long i was
like we can watch that yeah we watch the
whole thing in like less than an hour
yeah so yeah if you have netflix it's
definitely worth watching and it's not a
huge time commitment if you like asian
horror you'll probably be into it yeah
all right so uh mango badger says he's
what he's gonna go ahead and he's uh
he's booking his viewing of uh the
artists out there
i'm plugging this [ __ ] again this is
one of the better one of the better
movies or one of the best movies of that
year that that came out in case you guys
have missed the beginning there's a lot
of truth in this movie it might be
spiritual truth
but there's a lot of truth to this movie
when it comes to um
self-defense martial arts guns and just
human nature there's a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] to learn in this [ __ ]
i love this movie she loved the movie i
love it i love this everything i don't
know why
jenny didn't think i was gonna like it
when we saw it it just didn't really
when we were watching it didn't really
seem like your thing because normally
like that kind of thing that's usually
my thing that's not usually your thing
i was pulled into it though yeah you saw
me getting pulled in that's what i mean
that's what was so unusual because
usually that you would hate that kind of
yeah
well this dude right here he's being
bullied and he is
so [ __ ] pitiful that it's he's so
[ __ ] soy that is disgusting but
they get him to man up you just got to
see it yourself just got to see yourself
if one thing leads to another and not
everything is as it appears
it's like it's a good flick i can't wait
to see it again i've seen it about three
times i'll be well i'm gonna watch this
one tonight
i'm excited um i'm excited to watch
bavaria yeah the very
moment because that's coming tomorrow
yeah but yeah so uh like i said if you
have
netflix and you're into korean horror
then uh check this one out he said
say look it says they're making fun of
sensei on the back it says
in the bonus features it says a special
message from sensei
so sensei gives you a special message
he's going to tell you that you have to
listen to death metal and
[Laughter]
i was like yeah that dog is too feminine
louis says are you gonna watch ratchet
on netflix i've thought about it i saw
it on look at it it looks good
which one's ratchet that's the one about
is it about nurse ratchet that's what i
thought just from like
glancing it really quick i don't know
there's a lot of stuff i have to watch
on netflix and like i said i'm not going
to say what it is and
maybe some people figured out but they
added a new movie on there that i just
happened to have ordered the book
to read for my horror book review show
so i might do the next
book review show on that book because
i'm almost done with the book and then
i'll watch the movie and then
i'll talk about it on the next one but
we'll see how that goes all right well
that out
that i gotta close it off for today i
think uh we could shut it down
yeah because i'm like i'm really sleepy
and i gotta yeah i gotta record a show
tonight
[Laughter]
but yeah we will be uh live streaming
again tomorrow probably do a side tracks
because i don't think we'll have time to
watch a new movie tonight because i
gotta record um
a show so uh we'll talk to you guys
again
tomorrow thanks for all the presents
thanks for dropping by
and uh we'll see you tomorrow bye